in this problem a given Community has a
current population of 30,000 residents
the town has recently started to smell
funny and their sports teams are all
doing poorly as such it has been
predicted that their population will
decrease by about 25% over the next 10
years as people move away in
disgust however this smelly unathletic
town is also concerned about climate
change and the larger storms that are
expected to impact it in 10 years the
wastewater treatment plant is planning
to change their Peak flow capacity from
2.5 times the daily flow to three times
the daily flow what is the new Peak flow
expected to be in 10 years in
MGD so this is a long problem to read
out but it's actually a very short one
to
solve the first thing to note about this
problem is that it doesn't require
anything from the reference manual
it gives you everything you need to
solve it right within the problem so
let's get to it step
one is to find the future expected water
use in 10 years we're just going to sum
the commercial and domestic flows that
are expected 10 years
later so from our table over here we can
see that 10 years later the expected
commercial use in gallons per cap cap
per day is 8 and the domestic is 45 so 8
+ 45 simply equals
gallons per
capita per
day step two we're going to find the new
expected population in 10 years
so so if our current population is
30,000
and it's expected to decrease by
25% all we have to do
is
30,000
time
75%
of the whole since that'll be what's
left and that'll give us
22,500
residence in this case you could replace
the word residence with
capita if it's going to help you out
with your unit conversion
later step three we're going to find the
daily flow rate in 10 years in
MGD
so so if we have
53 gallons per capita
Day
times
capita that's going to give
us just about
2500 gallons per day since capita will
cancel
out and this number is the same
as if we go so 10 to the 1 2 3 4 5 6
that's the same number as
1.19
25 million gallons per
day and now we have step four find the
peak flow in 10 years the problem tells
us that the new Peak flow is going to be
three times the daily flow so all we
have to do here is 1.1 1
MGD *
3 and that's going to give us
35775 mg
D and that's the answer to our problem
and if we look over here the closest
answer is going to be
3.6 so yeah this problem is pretty
straightforward there's nothing needed
from the manual you just need to make
sure that you are using the values
required for future predictions over
here and not those in the present day
which are just meant to trick
you and again it's a long problem to
read through but everything you require
is right here and that's
it